hello and welcome to insight Germany
today my guest is the first organist
ever to be nominated for a Grammy he's
most probably the first organist who
doesn't play in churches at all but in
concert halls
he's also been called the on for tarry
blur of the pipe organ Liberace meets
Billy Idol and the list goes on the fact
is that Cameron carpenter is a virtuoso
musician who is trying to
single-handedly dragged kicking and
screaming the image of organ music and
organists into the 21st century
welcome to the show would that be a fair
description No thank you Robert I mean
it's hard to say what what would make it
fair or not fair I don't know if it's
quite fair to Billy Idol I suppose we've
slipped into a situation in the late or
in the late 20th century which remains
that we have to to describe any artists
compare them to others not your fault by
the way it it just happens to all of us
but I've always felt that somehow the
description whether you relate it to
meet a Billy Idol or David Bowie or
Liberace or all of those things one is
trying to describe something that that
in in known terms but it's hard to do
because the organ in in the modern era
is an unknown thing it's it's been with
us for hundreds of years but it's so old
that to make it new again
we are almost without context and I
think that's where all those to me
rather strange but essentially
flattering descriptions come from so you
don't you don't mind them I mean at
least you're getting attention and I
mean ah and she was more the kicking and
screaming bringing the organ into the
21st century that I was interested well
I think it you know the funny thing
about the organ is that it is it is
always described as having a soul or all
of these you know human characteristics
when of course an organ like a race car
or like any great machine that's finely
tuned is of course a soulless entity it
is a machine that
it's soul from its operator or its
player so I I'm very particular about
that because for me the the height of
the organ and this is this is to be
found especially in the digital organ is
that most finely tuned machine which in
fact has no innate personality or
identity of its own but which deeply and
intensely truly channels that of the
person playing it the better to serve
music or whatever the machine was
designed to do so by definition the
organ itself can't kick her screen
Organists on the other hand are more
than happy to do their their share of
screaming I've yet to actually be kicked
but it has come close yeah yeah I mean
it's such a versatile instrument but its
image is quite I mean it's sort of I try
to think of the words you know it's
image is terrible if you like it's a
it's a disaster yeah yeah um well I mean
an are you changing it is that your God
well I would not say that it's my goal
um my goal of course is to have as
broadly international and musically
diverse a life as I can with my
instrument and that's probably a goal
that is totally classical in the sense
that almost every musician I think wants
wants basically that they we all as
musicians want to experience the most of
music that we can in the course of
growing up to be an organist and and and
discovering as a child as I did and as
most ordnance to this incredible machine
and trying to come to terms with how you
relate to it or don't perhaps in some
cases we all have to define what it is
that we want and I think when you study
music and you spend the life in music
you begin to as you mature or at least
age in my case you begin to I think but
you I think both are beginning to have
that you you begin to assemble your
musical identity in your personality
you begin to pull together the character
you want and for a lot of people to play
that the organ I think very genuinely
and and and honestly that character is
best to be found in liturgy and in the
music of the church for me music has is
inextricably related to performance and
performance not just in the strict
classical sense of interpretation the
Romantic tradition or the classical
tradition but performance also in the
20th and 21st centuries sense of
performances performance art performance
as influenced by now 50 or more years of
rock and roll performance is influenced
by what it takes to become to be at once
conversant with your classical
discipline in your practice but yet be
viable as a commercial entity and then
of course the ongoing struggle and the
any continually quickly evolving
questions of how what we've come to
understand is classical music does or
doesn't relate to the larger music Oh
commercial infrastructure of the world
and in all of those things the disaster
for the organ is the image and what you
quickly discover when you scratch the
surface of anything relating to the
organ is that paradox is almost innate
the the great paradox of the organ is
that it seems to be this hidebound
earthbound inflexible instrument when in
reality it is the greatest instrument
not because of its size or grandiosity
certainly not in my opinion because of
any solar day Oh Gloria but definitely
because of its malleability and it's
great versatility well we'll find out
more about that later on I want to just
show you this picture that you sent us
how did it all start I do that on my
business no doubt I would send that
really myself oh this is a picture of
you actually played the piano that's me
a piano how did you we'll start then
with the organ well um my recollection
is that there was never a time without
the organ and the piano i dident Lehrer
member I think I think I was four I
definitely remember the
I'm that I was learning to grasp the
mechanism of the keyboards but my first
really deep meaningful musical memory
which I've probably over
intellectualized in hindsight but which
I remember shining Li is the first time
I touch the keyboard of the organ at at
a small Church in Meadville Pennsylvania
and this experience of pushing down a
key and remaining with your hand down on
the key and the sound continuing think
for a minute even even even if the the
common man's understanding of the piano
we know that when you push the key when
you slam the key you get a loud sound
and when you touch the key briefly you
get a softer sound and that that's sort
of the essence of the playing of the
piano but underneath that lies the
reality that when you stop playing the
sound will die away on the organ this
isn't true when you hold the key the
sound will continue and while I couldn't
have verbalize it at the time I
absolutely convinced that when you hold
the key because the sound continues at
the same rate at which it was initiated
you effectively are not controlling just
the sound but our perception of time and
it's that touch of the texture of time
that for me is the essence of playing
the organ and that was how it began well
okay now let's hear the man play first
of all and find out more we met up with
him recently here in Berlin
cameron carpenter is dusting down works
by famous composers such as johann
sebastian bach in his own inimitable
style carpenter won the coveted leonard
bernstein award in 2012 and is the first
organist ever to get a grammy nomination
he fills concert halls from New York to
Tokyo this image of the organ as
something which gives us this this very
droning boring horrible thing that goes
along with no rhythm and slowly makes us
feel guilty and wish we were in hell
which we already are there's certainly
nothing dull about Cameron's passionate
playing
the ultimate difference of what I'm
doing
will sound self-serving I suppose but
the ultimate difference is me of course
because my feeling my passion and my
experience of the organ has to be
reckoned with in terms of the very blood
of my life is something that nobody else
can feel playing the organ like this is
physically demanding to keep in shape
the Pennsylvania born berlin-based
musician goes to the gym every day but
Carpenter is more than just an athletic
virtuoso he pays attention to every
detail he's also making bold fashion
statements
he even designs some of his stage
outfits himself it's not just the music
the look is important too
one can't talk very well about style and
fashion and go on stage to show those
things unless one is conversant with the
world of fashion which means that you
need to look like a model and my
challenge as an artist is not just to
play music but to bring the highest work
I do into a light in which it can be
seen and understood by the people of our
time Cameron carpenter already has a
spectacular act but he's not resting on
his laurels he's working on his legacy
in another way he's designed and
patented his vision of the organ of
tomorrow a digital portable instrument
which could become part of music history
having proved itself in the studio this
touring instrument is now set to go out
on the road
talking about the organ having proved
itself in the studio you've you've done
the album but it's not released yet but
we will be giving one away later in the
show although we don't have it
physically in our hand
did I see there in your apartment here
in Berlin that you have an organ that's
right
how are the neighbors they haven't
complained yet but I think it's mostly
because they're never there one of the
great things about living in Berlin
which was for instance really hard to
achieve in New York is having space not
only for instruments but space for music
making in space where you can establish
yourself within a large building that
where you know other people are living
as having the right to make music
something that's actually taken for
granted in Berlin or seems to be whereas
in New York it was always a constant
battle with the neighbors not just for
the organ it turns out to have been the
piano that makes the most problem for
some reasons really was was classical
music actually your first connection to
Germany I mean I think it was um my my
my real taste of of what it might be
like to live here was quite a surprise
to me I played in 2008 I was invited to
play at the gov and house in Leipzig and
it was the middle of the winter and I
came and something about the trip
remains in my mind is just this very
peaceful sort of enlightened experience
both the incredible audience at the
given house as well as I mean I guess
you wouldn't necessarily say the beauty
of Leipzig but the the this strength of
the stark impression of the you know
some of the communist architecture and
in the snow and everything it was such a
different experience for me
and out of that trip I ended up meeting
two
people who became my two best friends in
life both of whom were German and over
the next couple of years by 2010 I had
been back several times and had had been
visited Berlin on each trip and every
time it became clearer to me that the
things that I were looking for around
every street corner in the East Village
and in you know in New York City and
around all the corners was actually to
be found in Berlin and so I moved that's
your reason for coming well there are
several reasons I never really have a
good single answer but I guess that's
also like Berlin I mean it's impossible
to say one single thing that that
identifies the city there are many
things and to understand them together
is a little bit complicated you also
talked in the report there about your
style and fashion is your style your
personal preference or are you doing
that sort of provoke that people watch
you that you're different to others I
don't think I'm that different to others
and I think that there's an organist um
yes I mean you know there's this picture
of Organists being in rather crufty old
suits that's fair I'm playing in
churches but I think I think I think
engaging in the assumption of that is is
automatically to to to participate
within it because to most people I think
the only idea they have of an organist
if any is a remote stereotype it's easy
enough of course to say that that
Organists are you know typically look a
certain way but anybody with the
slightest intellectual inquiry at all
will realize that such a stereotype as a
certain value but that when we say that
about anyone we could never really be
that correct on a case-by-case basis I
think the image of the organist has more
to do with a sort of mental a sort of
mental making an image out of what's
heard because the the
the the way that we view organist and
the stereotypical view of an organist is
dusty to me has more to do with the way
Organists typically sound and what their
sound might be able to be construed to
be here described as then what the
people themselves are actually like let
me show a picture though elf is I don't
know did you send us this one okay well
that's certainly one I've approved that
some things are designed and that's look
at your design that's something I'm I
was wearing on stage couple of years ago
this is sort of toreador yes it is
you'll find also that some of my some of
the things I like to wear are a little
bit military encourage that well the the
toreador and and and in the military
this is this sort of military jacket I
also was doing something with a subtle
camouflage that of course is is a
conscious thing I like to like to think
about the image of the organist as being
a musical warrior and as being a
champion I suppose a person who is
religious might in the same character
try to imagine it as the avenging angel
of the organ or somesuch or maybe there
it might be even a marquee astok
reverence because there is an element of
contending with the Beast whether you
view that as the forces of evil or the
or the the bowl to the toreador or the
opposing forces to the general there is
something about the organ that it
represents a massive force that has to
be conquered to be turned to good and
the the conference of course is really
of oneself one has to grasp totally
one's abilities you have to have in
playing the organ you have to have a
mental acuity that allows you to grasp
many different musical ideas and
physical activities simultaneously of
course you have to have I think it helps
to have a very athletic frame of mind
and and and and a physical willingness
to
take physical risks and to and to exert
yourself you can't have a few it's like
playing the pedals we saw a teen little
bit in that clip with I think we see a
little bit more in the next clip but
I've never seen anybody play the pedals
that fast and you design your own shoes
- I do yeah I mean and and in the case
of the the the touring organ the pedal
board for the first time for what we
think is the first time has been
radically expanded to have even more
notes come on which is partly my it's
partly an outgrowth of my feeling that I
want to be able to play with the same
fluidity and and and hopefully grace
expressivity and porce but also
technical you know facility with the
feet as with the hands it's probably
never truly achievable but it's it's
it's the idea of pushing towards that
and just sorry to just show these shoes
on to the organ playing those shoes
aren't necessarily for it would be for
any specific thing it would be hard to I
mean this is going back to the style
thing these you designed for well that's
right those are those are shoes I've
decorated and and those are those are
made for a couple of certain outfits and
you stumble now or or perhaps hit upon
intentionally a an interesting point
which is or an interesting question I
suppose what is the role of fashion what
could be the role of style rather than
fashion for a person who's if not in
embroiled exclusively in an intellectual
pursuit which some would say music is at
least devoted to a life work which would
seem to have an abstract nature which
music is for me those things are
absolutely related the to begin with
music for me is is not an intellectual
pursuit I don't consider myself an
intellectual at all only absolutely not
you are I thank you I appreciate I
appreciate things I don't think that I
am I don't intellectualize a lot of
things don't you think I think I
probably pseudo-intellectual eyes a lot
but I I don't consider myself an
intellectual simply because I don't I
don't think that my mind were
works at its best and does things that
are interesting to others in in an
intellectualizing way it the things that
I have to bring to the world that are of
the most worth are done from a place
which is not really possible to put into
words and which I think derive their
most meaningful impact and result from
themselves which is to say what happens
during an improvisation during a concert
or my transcription of a movement from a
Tchaikovsky Symphony or Bernstein's
Candide overture or what happens on the
touring organ for instance when I play
music by Leonard Cohen or Patsy Cline or
Gershwin or let's say when you talk to
couplers I'm just showing this picture
to go with please keep talking but this
is now a picture of the touring organ
which now exists that's the
international touring organ as built by
the company Marshall and this is the
fact I mean we should explain that of
course an organist I think is the only
instrumentalist who cannot play his own
instrument you could say pianists to a
certain extent but I'll be honest
Trane's frequently travel I think a
Christian Zimmerman and some of the
others or what's you genus tow man who
traveled with their on pianos but this
this is the first ever touring orbit
it's not it does not it's what it is is
the I think it's the great triumph of
technology over over the what have been
up until this point in arguable
realities of the organ I would submit
made of this huge punch well that what I
said earlier that the organ is defined
by paradox and there you know it is it
is the instrument that that has the
greatest musical spectrum I mean not not
to address this sort of Wooley debatable
areas of of the pseudo mystic or of
personal beliefs such as what makes
music or what makes an organ great or
what expression is but to simply just
look at the facts the the instrument as
musical entity has a very
three-dimensional space in which it
lives to begin with it has the the
widest spectrum of pitch the instrument
can play notes that are lower all the
way up to notes that are higher than any
other instrument yeah and it has
obviously of course a parallel
composition of loudest sounds to that of
almost inaudible 'ti and of course the
aspect of time that a note held will
continue to sound I think it's a good
moment one organ you play on a
reasonably regular basis I think is the
one in the Berlin Philharmonic Hall
that's right and not long ago Cameron
had a special day there with some kids
and a recent guest on our show
Sarah Willis and let's have a look at
some of the highlights and you'll see
the organ inside of it everything
Cameron is a superstar demons eat water
yeah
or even the Camerons eat me so guns
Alvie so the two pushers on tax form
attacks
Organists also hidden files eat and it
does be older and Cameron you use your
feet a lot and you have these special
shoes does the cameras get them he makes
them himself a Marty's a bar
these are tons of shoe tolerance for
Latin dance airspeed off on the
Philharmonia or go can you tell us
Cameron about the phenomena organism
this is the spill Tish of the the neues
spiel tisha the philomene yoga and it's
organ by karl shuker or Gopal here in
Berlin I don't um Cameron uh he is a
clip of mahon dance Rashid Nat Turner
they all make each one is like each one
is like one one instrument sort of a
year in office or an instrument I also
think be an instrument
this is fluid to name again Jesus horn
what's the horn
not-so-nice can you tell us a little bit
about what goes on up here
well no no I think you should go up you
think I should you should go unless you
want to play and I can go up oh no I
don't have I hope my shoes aren't nice
enough
Divac billion our countrymen decently
fuzz pedals tendencies the feet
yeah the bass pedals and those are five
and one holds and also there's there's
metal pipes would pipes but these are
wood it would but outlet CJ's kog'maw
heavier ball as he omit me and my
cameraman on there are murder mostly
here attention woman Korean boys
committed here tying the finish Bannon
this isn't mobile ampere so dusty Martin
this holds me fish he isn't Viet sin or
girl home told touch panels it can void
better region about Nixon its Infinix of
Ipek whose idea ah ok office good does
this good Cameron
they're all these weird-looking things
here everything in there looks weird
let's let's get in there on the camera
see it's like I'm clarinet for each note
there's this little part inside and that
that little thing in there is vibrating
I don't think you're ready for this okay
Mike okay ready three
now it was good to see the inner
workings for those who don't know anyway
my guest Cameron carpenter playing and
explaining how the organ works and
deafening Sara Willis there if you'd
like to win a signed copy of Cameron's
upcoming new CD please write to us at
insight at DWD you may notice that I'm
not showing the CD because it hasn't
come out yet
but as we said earlier you've made the
CD and as soon as it's released I a copy
will be on its way to the winner of the
draw and the address will come up again
at the end of the show um what's that we
play the theme tune of The Simpsons yeah
of course justice what happened to occur
to me at the time probably a flagrant
violation of licensing yeah we move on
you said recently and I quote I'm
convinced that the pipe organ is
finished now some people might accuse
you of being a heretic I mean the sound
of a pipe organ can it really I mean
your digital touring organ can it really
reproduce that huge sound yeah of course
and I think it's it's important to state
that what means finished for me might be
a starting point for someone else
there's a lot of things about the pipe
organ that are that have been
incontrovertible realities up until this
point the first of them and and probably
in my in my feeling the most damning is
the fact that the pipe organ literally
isn't going anywhere
meaning the greatest organ in the world
does it have to go anyway I mean it does
it has to and there are reasons it has
to it has to to be a personal intimate
musical machine and I think it has to to
become compatible or to participate in
what I like to call the musical
commercial infrastructure of today a
great deal of the pipe organs life and
and many of its most illustrious moments
have happened under the hands of people
who
primarily not concerned with musical
commerce either because they were in the
service of the church or because they
were playing I think of for instance the
great French organist Marcel do preyas
and msu playing at a time when the tides
of culture were shifting in directions
more friendly to an instrument which was
accepted to have come from the church
and could be heard only in the church
then would ever be practical now I mean
you obviously your Seva I mean you
obviously changing this but I mean for
instance with the organ with the touring
organ aren't you going to have your back
to the audience oh yeah of course I have
no problem having my back to the
audience the point of the touring organ
has not been to translate the organ
through the digital realm into something
which is immediately consumable without
work the only point of the Turing organ
is to make a single great organ
transportable anywhere in the world and
to keep it consistent from venue to
venue we have had before touring organs
the great American organist at in 1960s
and 70s a touring organ which used less
technology than it is in that tablet it
was a totally analog instrument and
whatever you might feel about analog
sound or however that instrument sounded
nobody could deny that that made him the
one organist in history to be able to
for instance play on Johnny Carson to
have a musical partnership with Liberace
to play in Carnegie Hall and many other
things so even 40 years ago it was
already there was already a proof
positive that to be able to participate
in modern musical commerce a musician
has to be able to move now what's
important also you have your own
instrument that's exactly what I was
going to say the instrument has
traditionally and historically been
least intimate of musical instruments it
is not only physically far away from us
as the listener we as the player are far
away from our audience well and you mix
with your audience before concerts
frequently do this
and do you do that here in Germany
surely I have done it yeah um I mean
I've done it in Asia I've done it in the
United States and I think it's I think
it's always important as a performer to
have a very very strong sense of where
one's inhibitions lie so that you can
overcome them I think that's one of the
things I believe so importantly in the
in the digital organ is that it allows
me many ways to overcome the the innate
inhibitions or what could be seen to be
the inbuilt inhibitions or limitations
of the pipe organ it's great distance
it's great removal and it's overbearing
sighs uh physical ER for me things which
can't only be seen as as grandiose or
and which shouldn't be necessarily
assumed to be good simply because their
monumental a monument after all is I'm
very fond of pointing out is frequently
something which is erected to something
we no longer remember and which no one
living is experienced and around which
traffic is diverted and it's that
diversion of traffic that concerns me
the most we must turn away from the
organ turn to our questionnaire that we
send out to our guests I want to ask you
some things about Germany all you
replied to something my pleasure and you
put down as your top down which
practically everybody does Berlin but
you put runner up keel so I wondered why
keel well keel as real as I've been told
by by people from there um keel is the
hometown of my best friend and a place
that was one of the probably the main
outlying German town or city small city
that I got to visit other than of course
Berlin we would go there and and and
visit friends and I was always overcome
with the beauty of the place not just in
terms of not so much in terms of the
town but in terms of it be
on the water and that it was somehow the
Easthampton of Germany or something with
the sailing and also the attitude of
sailing but you know pretty much every
question on that questionnaire in as
much as it relates to a city I could
only ever really answer in terms of
people because it's the people that have
made Germany a warm place or an
interesting place for me one can talk
about so many other things we can talk
about the German food and the German
organs there was knowledge the ceaseless
amp'd yes but its eyes of the eye the
eye farm which is where I work it is
that this is the office of weights and
measures is that that's right right and
you put that down you put down this this
this this
the calibration mark on the wineglass
sure you're fading the favorite German
culinary achievement for me that's um
that's it that's that's a very loaded
answer because of course to consider a
tiny mark engraved on a glass as the
greatest German culinary achievement is
to make a very snide remark about German
food um but I find it actually funnier
in the sense that um first of all I
always thought there should be a joke
that there's an opt for that because in
in tech and in the United States you can
always say well there's an app for that
but in Germany there really isn't opt
for that almost everything is governed
by an aunt and in this case I found it
very funny because the the the office of
weights and measures I suppose could be
seen to be making sure not an engraved
line to tell you how much you drank it
has nothing about keeping you sober
rather it's to make sure you got the
alcohol you paid for okay which I sort
of thought makes it an opt dedicated to
making sure you have a good time yeah
let's move on you write that the coolest
German historically is Magnus Hirschfeld
that's a doctor and sexologist who is
now spoken advocate for sexual
minorities let's find out a little more
about his work and indeed the history of
the gay liberation movement here
in Europe we're talking very very early
on you mentioned Meadville where you
grew up little town in Mid America I
mean is that another reason that you
like Germany the social freedoms here
are different perhaps well I love the
social freedoms in Germany there's no
question about that it would be very
very wrong of me to imply that I ever
experienced any strong discrimination in
the United States my life has been
extremely fortunate in that way I've
I've experienced a little discrimination
here or there but nothing nothing
traumatic or painful as many of my
friends and lovers have and why do you
think it's a more open society here I do
think this it I do think Germany is as a
society more open than the United States
the United States is is is such a
paradoxical place and one that's
difficult to understand when you're
there it's it's a little easier to see
it from from from the perspective of now
as I do living and living in Europe I
love the United States very much but
it's such a vast place for one thing it
really is about five vaguely unified
countries you have the South which is
certainly its own world you have New
England of course which is totally
totally different there's the great
swath of Midwest California could be
considered to be sort of a nation state
in its own as is New York City obviously
so you have these these places you have
Los Angeles in New York which is sort of
great barges moored to this other nation
and then you have these these places
where there are localities and views
that vary and and and rights even of
course the very state by state and but
people perhaps it's a cliche but people
would say but here in Jerry there's so
many rules and regulations of course
famously yes I mean Germany is a highly
regulated society but it's also a
society that has recently experienced
grave censorship I mean even even
especially in Berlin I mean you can see
the resistance to surveillance
the resistance to the recent NSA
revelations and problems that is so
outspoken in Germany and one has to look
to the immediate history of the Stasi of
course to see that people are still you
will still meet people on the street who
personally experienced that this is the
East German secret base the stars
exactly so so and of course living in my
neighborhood even within the former GDR
you know that you'll you you're never
very far from that history nor are you
of course very far from from the history
of the early in the mid twentieth
century and the horrible years so I
think that that recent experience and
also the geographic locality of it is
simply so much a part of you know of
life here not just in Berlin but in
Germany that we don't I mean I can
promise you there's there's no remote
way to understand it anywhere in the
United States in the same fashion and I
think because of that despite the fact
that Germany is a highly regulated
socialist society that in fact the ones
degree of personal freedom within that
regulation is is much richer and
certainly much more well protected
nationally and internationally within
Europe so do you think finally we've run
out of time I'm amazed it's gone like a
flash but do you think this is home is
this home for you now are you staying I
think so I think Germany is one of one
of one of two homes I mean I'll always
be an American but I'm an American who
has chosen to live here because I felt
it would enrich my life if only I would
have known in those first the first few
weeks of thinking that how much it would
enrich my life I would have done it even
much much sooner so yes I mean it you've
enriched our life thank you very much
look look out for Cameron carpenter on
tour in a concert hall near you now with
the organ that's traveling around it's
gonna travel all around the world and
into Germany many times in May 2014 yeah
cameron carpenter thanks very much for
being with AC thank you for watching do
write in to us and talk about anything
you like and also you could get into the
draw for Cameron Carter's CD which will
be hot off the press soon that's it bye
bye until next time Cheers
you